TUCKER.
THAT'S "THE STORY."
TUCKER CARLSON IS UP NEXT.
GOOD NIGHT, EVERYBODY.
♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS
LONG BEEN A COLLECTION OF
DEEPLY UNHAPPY INTEREST
GROUPS THAT SECRETLY HATE
EACH OTHER.
BUT, FOR THE LAST THREE
YEARS IT'S BEEN FAIRLY
SIMPLE TO KEEP THAT
FRACTIOUS COALITION TOGETHER
YOU FOCUS ON DONALD TRUMP.
DESPISING DONALD TRUMP AND
JUMPING UP AND DOWN HOW MEAN
AND IMMORAL HE IS.
SOMETHING THEY CAN AGREE ON.
NANCY PELOSI WAS HOPING IT
WOULD LAST FOREVER.
THE LAST ELECTION SEASON
INTRUDED AND DEMOCRATS HAVE
A FEW MONTHS TO CHOOSE THEIR
PARTY'S NOMINEE THEIR
STANDARD BEARER THAT MEANS
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN A LONG
TIME THEY HAVE NO CHOICE BUT
TO FOCUS ON EACH OTHER.
THE MOST MISERABLE PEOPLE
YOU KNOW STUCK TOGETHER IN
AN ELEVATOR FOR ETERNITY.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS LIKE.
NATURALLY CNN IS RIGHT IN
THE MIDDLE OF IT.
THE CHANNEL SHADOWY
PRESIDENT JEFFREY ZUCKER HAS
JOINED FORCES WITH ELIZABETH
WARREN AND HER CAMPAIGN TO
CRUSH THEIR COMMON ENEMY,
BERNIE SANDERS.
JUST BEFORE TUESDAY NIGHT'S
DEMOCRATIC DEBATE, WARREN
USED CNN TO ATTACK SANDERS
AS A SEXIST, NOT SEXY, BUT
SEXIST.
FOR SAYING A WOMAN COULD NOT
BE ELECTED PRESIDENT.
SANDERS DENIED SAYING IT.
AFTER THE DEBATE, WARREN
MARCHED OVER TO SANDERS AND
BARKED AT HIM, PRESUMABLY AT
WARREN'S REQUEST, CNN LATER
RELEASED THAT TAPE.
WATCH HOW IT WENT, INCLUDING
A SPECIAL GUEST APPEARANCE
BY TOM STEYER WHO SUDDENLY
LOOKS TINY AND AFRAID.
>> I THINK YOU CALLED ME A
LIAR ON NATIONAL TV?
>> WHAT?
>> I THINK YOU CALLED ME A
LIAR ON NATIONAL TV?
>> LET'S NOT DO IT RIGHT
NOW.
YOU WANT TO HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION, WE WILL HAVE
THAT DISCUSSION.
YOU CALLED ME A LIAR.
YOU CALLED ME -- WOE WON'T
GET INTO IT RIGHT NOW.
>> I JUST WANTED TO SAY HI,
BERNIE.
>> OKAY, GOOD.
>> Tucker: ELIZABETH WARREN
IS NOT SOMEONE YOU WOULD
WANT TO HAVE DINNER WITH.
TELL HER YOU ARE BUSY IF SHE
CALLS.
WHAT ELSE DOES THAT VIDEO
PROVE?
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
NOT ONE THING.
WE'RE IN THE VERY SAME PLACE
WE WERE AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE WEEK WITH AN AGING
UNPROVABLE ALLEGATION THROWN
ONTO THE FIELD IN
DESPERATION BY A FADING
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE WHO
SEEMS MORE UNLIKEABLE BY THE
DAY.
IT WOULD GET NOWHERE IN
COURT.
BUT OVER AT CNN, WHERE BEING
A HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT FROM
KENTUCKY IS CONSIDERED
GROUNDS FOR CHARACTER
ASSASSINATION, IT'S ENOUGH
TO SHOW CONCLUSIVELY THAT
BERNIE SANDERS HATES WOMEN.
WATCH THE ANALYSIS.
♪ I AM STRONG
♪ I AM INVINCIBLE
♪ INVINCIBLE
♪
>> Tucker: I'M SORRY, WE
PULLED THE WRONG TAPE FROM
OUR FAMILY
OUR FEMILY
OUR FEMINY
OUR FEMINIST OUTRAGE FILE.
MORE EMBARRASSING.
>> IT WAS SO REAL THE
MOMENT -- HER, HOWEVER YOU
WANT TO DESCRIBE IT, HER
FRUSTRATION, HER ANGER, HER
DESIRE TO HAVE -- MAKE THIS
POINT TO BERNIE SANDERS WAS
CRYSTAL CLEAR.
>> SO YOU CAN CLEARLY
UNDERSTAND HER FURY AT THAT.
AND, AGAIN, IT'S ONE OF
THOSE MOMENTS YOU DON'T SEE
VERY OFTEN IN POLITICS WHERE
SHE FELT VERY FRUSTRATED,
USED WHATEVER WORDS YOU
WANT, AND SHE JUST WENT OVER
TO HIM AND TOLD HIM WHAT SHE
WAS THINKING.
>> I AGREE WITH HILLARY, IT
WAS SURREAL.
SHE WAS PISSED OFF.
>> PEOPLE I HEARD ALL DAY
SHE KNEW SHE WAS MICKED.
SHE DID THAT ON PURPOSE.
THAT, TO ME DID NOT LOOK
LIKE AN ON PURPOSE.
LOOKED LIKE SHE WAS SEETHING
THROUGH THAT PART OF THE
DEBATE.
WHO DO WE BELIEVE?
LIKE I BELIEVE ELIZABETH
WARREN.
SHE IS FEELING UNDER THE
GUN.
SHE IS FEELING JUDGED AS A
WOMAN.
I THINK THERE IS AN
INSENSITIVITY LIKE HER
FRUSTRATION ON THAT.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
IT WAS TOTALLY AUTHENTIC.
THIS TIME CNN TELLS US, THIS
TIME ELIZABETH WARREN WAS
BEING 100 PERCENT COMPLETELY
REAL NOT LIKE THAT TIME SHE
LIED ABOUT HER RACE OR THE
TIME SHE LIED ABOUT HER JOB
HISTORY OR THE TIME SHE LIED
ABOUT HER PLAN TO FINANCE
UNIVERSAL HEALTHCARE WITHOUT
A MIDDLE CLASS TAX HIKE, NO,
NO, NO.
THIS TIME FOR SURE NO
QUESTION AT ALL ELIZABETH
WARREN IS TELLING THE WHOLE
TRUTH AND NOTHING BUT AND
YOU WOULD HAVE TO BE SOME
KIND OF MISOGYNIST TO DOUBT
HER.
THAT'S WHAT THEY TOLD US ALL
NIGHT ON CNN.
WHY TELL US THAT?
WHY LIE TO US?
SIMPLE THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL COMMITTEE IS
WORRIED ABOUT BERNIE
SANDERS.
ALL THOSE ATTACKS ON WALL
STREET OFFEND DONORS.
SO JEFF ZUCKER, A DEMOCRATIC
PARTISAN SAID REPEATEDLY HE
PLANS TO RUN FOR OFFICE ONCE
HE IS FINISHED RUINING CNN.
STOP THE BERNIE MENACE
BEFORE VOTERS COULD ELECT
HIM.
THAT'S WHAT YOU ARE
WATCHING.
THE MEDIA WORKING AS ALWAYS
TO THE HAND MAIDENS TO THE
RULING CLASS.
NOT JUST ON CNN.
THE "L.A. TIMES" PRAISED
WARREN FOR REFUSING TO SHAKE
HIS HAND.
MASTER CLASS IN HANDLING
SEXISM.
OKAY.
IS ANY OF THIS TRUE?
IS IT REAL?
SANDERS IS A SOCIALIST,
OBVIOUSLY.
BUT IS HE A SEXIST?
CONSIDER THIS:  ACCORDING TO
ANALYSIS BY BREITBART,
SANDERS PAYS HIS FEMALE
CONGRESSIONAL STAFFERS
$3.5000 MORE PER YEAR ON
AVERAGE THAN ELIZABETH
WARREN DOES.
AND YET, ACCORDING TO CNN,
ELIZABETH WARREN IS THE REAL
CHAMPION OF WOMEN.
SO WHAT'S THE EFFECT OF THIS
DEBATE?
MICHAEL MOORE ISN'T MUCH OF
A FILMMAKER FOR THAT MATTER
MUCH OF A PERSON HE KNOWS AN
AWFUL LOT OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
WATCH HIS ANALYSIS.
>> I HAVE KNOWN BERNIE SINCE
THE 1980s, SO, THERE IS NO
WAY HE SAID ANYTHING LIKE
THE WAY IT'S BEEN REPORTED.
THEY WILL MARK THIS DAY,
JANUARY 13TH, AS THE DAY
DONALD TRUMP WAS REELECTED.
>> Tucker: SO TRUMP IS THE
BENEFICIARY SAYS MICHAEL
MOORE.
HE MAY BE ON TO SOMETHING.
CONSIDER FOUR YEARS AGO
DEMOCRATS RIGGED THE PRIMARY
FOR HILLARY CLINTON.
THEY DID THAT DESPITE THE
FACT THAT HILLARY CLINTON
WOULD HAVE WON ANYWAY.
THEY COULDN'T RESIST
CHEATING.
BECAUSE THEY DID THAT,
BECAUSE THEY CHEATED,
MILLIONS OF DEMOCRATIC
VOTERS EMERGED FROM THE
PROCESS INBITTERRED AND
ENRAGED.
SOME OF THEM STAYED HOME
LAST NOVEMBER.
OTHERS VOTED FOR JILL STEIN
OR GARY JOHNSON.
SOME MOVED OVER TO TRUMP.
THEY SUFFERED SHOCKING UPSET
ON ELECTION DAY.
COULD THAT HAPPEN AGAIN?
OBVIOUSLY IT COULD.